what did it look like when you were
growing up cuz this is brand new nothing
like this is this is Disneyland compared
to how we grew up we're here in New
Orleans and it's been ten years since
Hurricane Katrina one of the biggest
natural disasters in US history not to
mention a massive political failure and
today some places like here in the Lower
Ninth Ward still look like this but
other places in New Orleans look a whole
lot different lately
this is bigwig developer pres Kabakov he
has a 1 billion dollar vision to turn
his hometown into an afro-caribbean
Paris you're like an urban boudu doctor
you're reviving deeper than my part now
who are you hoping to attract to condos
and places like these downtown new
luxury we've got lots of people like you
that are coming to town 30,000 of them
it took many years to make people
comfortable but now this urban
revitalization not only in New Orleans
but all over the country is becoming are
you actually seeing New Orleans natives
moving into places like these absolutely
but that's not what we've heard we
visited one of Quebec auvs mixed-income
properties with Kevin Kevin grew up in
housing projects here before the city
tore them down after Katrina in fact
only a fraction of public housing
residents were able to move into the new
mixed income developments like this one
so you don't see the jobs coming along
with the development no no no it's first
and not not be not the jobs that are
paying because most of the jobs that are
part of development are not going to
residents they're going to people that
are coming in from out of town how that
make you feel that it took Katrina to
then get this to get pressure-washed
did break it makes you feel but it makes
you felt like you weren't worth the
investment
housing advocates say the city didn't
have a sufficient plan to help restore
homes and keep housing accessible New
Orleans is a city that contains a
majority of renters
because friends have increased so much
then lower-income people no longer have
access to the neighborhoods in which
they've traditionally lived Neil is
trying to help curb rapid gentrification
by keeping locals in their neighborhoods
he uses tax incentives to flip historic
houses and then rents them at affordable
rates
they're just a stylistic difference some
like more green now this house is about
to fall down it couldn't have made it
many more months a lot of the homes we
renovate we try to keep as rental
housing because there is a rental market
in New Orleans not everybody is going to
be a homeowner
and so the niche that we try to fill is
for the residents that can't afford
their own home but that want to live and
their neighborhood where they grew up or
a historic New Orleans neighborhood and
so we cater to those folks and try to
keep them in neighborhoods that are
gentrifying such as this one if such
efforts are rare we met Ansel in Treme
the oldest black neighborhood in the
country now you look at the makeup of
the neighborhood unfortunate
gentrification is happening all over the
city and residents from this era being
pushed to New Orleans East
didn't you get a cool gourmet coffee
shop that has like you know you know
homemade granola bars
you know people from the residence here
weren't worried about that people wanted
to come home so they could just live
their normal lifestyle to get a real
taste of gentrification we checked out
st. Roch market a chic foodie paradise
that sticks out like a sore thumb in
what used to be a predominantly poor
black Weaver
they have like three dollars oh boy here
there's like no black customers
see I thought there was one but I think
she's filling out a job application back
in the Lower Ninth Ward
another black neighborhood that was
devastated by the storm Bernal has used
his life savings to restore the only
place to buy food for miles
he's now raising money to open more
services like a laundromat I'm trying to
raise 80,000 not to some people that's a
drop in the bucket someone let's say
like a Donald Trump he uploaded in the
night but to the lord night war that
would change everything and when people
see New Orleans they see the Bourbon
Street they see the French quarters but
they don't see what's going on right
here and if we wouldn't have done this
if we wasn't ahead nothing
it's the land of dreaming see this